bonsoir pour moi l'interrogation sur les
jeunes de banlieue elle a commencé avec
des manifestations qui étaient liées au
contexte géopolitique de l'été 2014
je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez de
ces manifestations en marge des cortèges
il y avait eu peut-être 100 150 jeunes
de banlieues qui était entré en conflit
physique avec les crs qui ré jeté des
pierres et il y avait eu une
photographie en particulier où on voyait
un jeune maghrébin torse nu avec le
caissier enroulé autour de la tête en
train de brandir une bière et à côté lui
il y avait une pile de pneus qui est en
train de brûler et cette photo-là
spécifiquement elle a fait le tour des
médias français une fois deux fois trois
fois
moi j'ai vu ça et j'ai entendu ce qui
était dit à ce moment-là sûr et je ne
m'en lieux et j'ai lu ce qui était écrit
à ce moment là sur les jeunes de
banlieue et j'ai eu la nausée
j'ai eu la nausée je me suis dit quelque
chose qu'on s'est tous dit au moins une
fois
quand on était jeune quand on était
gamin je me suis dit c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste de parler des jeunes de
banlieue comme ça le thème qu'on aborde
c'est celui de vivre ensemble pour vivre
ensemble la condition minimale la
condition indispensable c'est de
regarder l'autre tel qu'il est et non
pas tel qu'on en a peur alors
je me suis dit puisque c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste au sens c'est une
injustice et c'est pas juste au sens
c'est un manque de justesse c'est
inexact
je me suis dit je vais aller me
documenter je vais lire des rapports je
vais bouffer des chiffres je vous en
faire bouffer un peu seule chose ce soir
je suis désolé davance je vais me
documenter je vais aller sur le terrain
pour voir ce qu'il ya derrière le mythe
du monstrueux jeunes de banlieue alors
je vous présente le monstrueux jeunes de
banlieue c'est quoi le monstrueux jeunes
des banlieues c'est un il est arabe ou
noir
il a une capuche il est mal rasé c'est
un garçon il n'y a que des garçons chez
le monstrueux jeunes de banlieue même si
dans la réalité c'est 50 % de filles
mais peu importe donc le monstrueux
jeunes de banlieue fondamentalement
qu'est ce qu'il fait dans la vie il fume
du shit il trafique la drogue
il vend des armes
il stocke des armes dans sa cave dans sa
cave il ya également des tours nantes où
il est en train de lire les défis avec
ses potes dans sa cave également dans la
même cave c'est vous dire à quel point
les surcharger il est également en train
de suivre les cours de l'islam des
banlieues l'islam des banlieues qui est
en train de lui dire et il est fou de
joie en entendant ça qu'il faut aller
partir faire le jihad pour aller ensuite
en syrie et lui fous de joie puisque ils
détestent la france il déteste les
français c'est à dire implicitement les
blancs il veut une seule chose aller
faire la guerre en syrie allahou akbar
et puis ensuite il va rentrer et puis va
tout faire péter parce qu'il est plein
de haine
et si tu n'es pas sage si tu ne manges
pas ta soupe
ce soir le jeune de pian le banlieue
viendra te chercher le jeune de banlieue
c'est le croquemitaine des temps
modernes
fondamentalement son but dans la vie
c'est violer votre femme et deux filles
c'est brûler votre bagnole et 7 voler
votre bien c'est un sauvage il parle
même pas français il s'habille n'importe
comment
il est violent et mal élevés il sent
mauvais tout ce que vous voulez en fait
toutes les tares possibles et
imaginables dans la société
cherchez pas il les a ça c'est le
monstrueux je ne vends lieu alors
maintenant
intéressons nous aux vrais jeunes de
banlieue alors y at il des criminels et
délinquants ou des bandes de jeunes
enfermés dehors à rien [ __ ] à faire
beaucoup de bruit le soir sans être pour
autant criminels ou délinquants est-ce
qu'il y en a oui je ne dis pas que ça
n'existe pas j'invite simplement à
quantifier les problèmes selon la façon
dont vous conter il ya approximativement
1 million et demi de jeunes de banlieues
en france six étaient tous des criminels
et des délinquants ce serait les
effectifs supérieurs à ceux de l'armée
rouge
petite parenthèse en réalité criminels
délinquants et bande en train de glander
dehors ça représente moins de 2% des
vrais jeunes de banlieue c'est ça la
réalité moins de 2%
les 98 % qui restent pas des criminels
pas les délinquants pas dans des bandes
donc quand on dit jeunes de banlieue on
pense tout de suite délinquants
criminels
il ya 98 % des vrais qui sont pas
concernés ça c'est pour la réalité
maintenant parlons du cinéma colonne de
gauche
la réalité colonne de droite
la représentation dans le cinéma
français ceux qui ont vu intouchable
lever la main d'accord tout le monde
bien intouchable ce formidable film sur
le vivre ensemble fait quoi parlons-en
omar sy joue bien je ne m'en lieu il
fait quoi dans la vie ce jeune de
banlieue représentative des jeunes de
banlieue c'est un voleur c'est un fumeur
de joints c'est là fraudeurs aux
allocations sociales
il fait semblant de chercher un boulot
mais c'est pour toucher les allocs il va
revenir dans le droit chemin en
fréquentant des gens des centres villes
ce qui lui permettra de remettre dans le
droit chemin aussi son petit frère qui
est au collège mais qui commence à
sécher les cours pour quoi faire déjà
pour aller dîner du shit exactement
bonne réponse pour aller du lait du shit
avec un gang
les producteurs de ce film sont des
récidivistes puisque
sorti en septembre 2015 un autre film je
vous résume le pitch deux collégiens de
beaulieu hésite pendant tout le film
entre deux chemins possibles travailler
dur pour réussir à l'école ou deal et du
shit car c'est bien connu pour les
jeunes de banlieue l'alternative ça se
résume à ça donc le cinéma français
accumule ses clichés là qui
correspondent à 2 % de la population
les vrais jeunes de banlieue j'ai un
scoop
les vrais jeunes de banlieue ça fait
plus de 15 ans qui disent plus y va eh
oui donc ceux qui se lance dans une
imitation oisive a en fait ils passent
pour des slides alors ça aussi c'est un
reproche qui est fait aux jeunes de
banlieue c'est de parler une langue qui
n'est pas vraiment du français qui est
un sabir hargneux et pathétiquement
hostile à la beauté ça n'est pas vrai
déjà un exemple de équivalent au 19e
siècle des jeunes de banlieue gavroche
gavroche dans les misérables
c'est un jeune pauvre des quartiers
périphériques bah oui c'est un jeune de
banlieue
alors il parle un français qui pour
l'époque est un français de mauvaise
qualité
mais en fait fondamentalement c'est ce
qu'on appelle un argot et donc les
misérables dans le bouquin les
misérables de victor hugo parle une
langue française qui n'est pas la même
que celle des gens de la haute de nos
jours les jeunes de banlieue parle un
argot qui correspond à leur condition de
revenus
et devinez quoi comme toujours depuis
des siècles la langue française évolue
d'abord dans les populations les plus
pauvres et ensuite ça devient du
vocabulaire qui est courant dans les
classes moyennes je vous donne un
exemple il ya une quinzaine d'années
personne ne disait dans la population
des centres villes qui fait maintenant
j'ai kiffé c'est parfaitement banal mais
ça vient des banlieues à l'origine
j'ajoute que sur l'idée par exemple que
le rap ce serait quelque chose qui n'a
pas de texte jeudi sap s'il ya des gens
en particulier de plus de 50 ans dans la
salle lisaient des textes de rap lisez
les et vous verrez qu'il ya de la poésie
urbaine dedans vous verrez qu'il ya des
textes absolument superbe et d'ailleurs
un exemple de jeunes des quartiers
populaires qu'on pourrait considérer
donc un jeune de banlieue à l'époque du
paris du 19ème siècle par un beau et rit
donc les poètes du béton ça vaut la
peine de s'intéresser à leurs textes en
fait alors j'en viens à l'islam
si je vous dis jeune femme de confession
musulmane
vous allez penser à une femme voilée
c'est automatique alors en vrai les
jeunes femmes de confession musulmane en
france 15 et ou pas la nationalité
française d'ailleurs celles qui portent
systématiquement le voile des quais
sortent de chez elles ces 7% celles qui
le portent parfois en sortant de chez
elle c'est 8% et les 85 % qui restent
sait jamais donc quand on dit jeune
femme de confession musulmane et que
tout de suite on parle du port du voile
il ya 85 % des femmes qui sont pas
concernés j'ajoute un petit détail il ya
la moitié des jeunes de banlieues qui
sont pas musulmans qui l'ont jamais été
bah oui parce que dans la population des
vrais jeunes de banlieue il n'y a pas
que des arabes
il n'y a pas que des gens qui viennent
de l'afrique subsaharienne il ya aussi
des descendants d'autres vagues
d'immigration aux platines europe
orientale principalement scoop il ya de
la diversité dans la population des
jeunes de banlieue il n'y a pas que nos
clichés alors plus largement sur la
pratique de l'islam en france
en fait ce qui est en train de se
produire
ça s'appelle la désislamisation il ya eu
la déchristianisation la chute de la
pratique religieuse chez les chrétiens
et maintenant on est trente ans a
assisté à une désislamisation alors je
sais ce qu un certain nombre de
personnes qui vont m'entendre dire ça se
disent mais quand même il ya de plus en
plus de barbus dans le quartier je vois
bien qu'il ya plus de voiles dans le rer
etc
oui aussi la grande masse
des jeunes de confession musulmane ils
sont de moins en moins pratiquants c'est
un fait vous pouvez regarder derrière
moi
ils sont moitié moins pratiquants que
ceux qui ceux qui ont plus de 50 ans
moitié moins
quand vous parlez d'un jeune de
confession musulmane qui va la prière
pour la mosquée le vendredi
là il y en a qu à 80 % qui sont pas
concernés par ce que vous racontez vous
rendez compte c'est énorme ce qui est
vrai par contre c'est qu'il ya une
minorité qui est de plus en plus
pratiquantes
en revanche est dans cette minorité il y
en a qui sont intégristes c'est la
minorité de la minorité et dans ces
intégristes il y en a qui sont prêts à
une action violente c'est la minorité de
la minorité de la minorité faut
quantifier les problèmes alors en
parlant des problèmes parlons des
problèmes qui touchent massivement les
vrais jeunes de banlieue et dans ce cas
là parlons plutôt du chômage
là c'est beaucoup plus massif là ça
touche vraiment du monde 10% le taux de
chômage pour l'ensemble de la population
c'est plus de 20% pour les jeunes de
banlieue et dans ce cas là tant qu'à
parler des problèmes parle aussi de la
ségrégation scolaire
qu'est ce que c'est la ségrégation
scolaire c'est quand comment voulez vous
qu'on arrive à des chances équitables de
succès dans la vie quand on a déboulé
aux deux pieds
déjà à l'école il ya une gare de triage
entre le collège et le lycée
si vous êtes dans les centres villes
vous êtes très bon au collège vous irez
à la voie royale
vous irez en première s est prof vous
pousseront à le faire si vous êtes très
bon au collège quand vous êtes dans un
lit dans un collège de banlieue au toi
tu es bon toi qui fera un super
mécanicien cherchez l'erreur
les jobs auquel on accède quand on est
jeune de banlieue
soit vous êtes au chômage soit vous êtes
dans des jobs précaires vous allez être
livreur vous allez être caissière
vous allez découvrir sur les toits vous
allez faire des boulots difficile avec
des horaires qui sont rudes mal payés il
ya une minorité qui va réussir à s'en
sortir en ayant des boulots qui
correspond pas à ce milieu là mais c'est
peanuts alors c'est quoi c'est parce
qu'ils sont mauvais non c'est parce
qu'ils ont déboulé à chaque pied y
compris parmi les bouley nos propres
préjugés
alors pourquoi finalement on diabolise
les jeunes de banlieue pourquoi on leur
donne tous les vices je dirais qu'il ya
fondamentalement deux raisons la
première c'est qu'on ne peut accepter la
façon dont on leur marche dessus que si
on les accable de tous les maux parce
que sinon si l'écrasante majorité n'a
rien à se reprocher alors c'est que
notre société est injuste et on est
obligé de le regarder en face et puis
une autre raison plus attristante
apparemment toute société a besoin d'un
bouc émissaire pour que ceux qui ne sont
pas ce bouc émissaire se sentent mieux
dans leurs pompes et donc dis moi tout
ce que tu attribues comme vis aux jeunes
de banlieue et je te dirai tout ce qui
va mal dans ta société
d'ailleurs vous savez quel nouveau
monstre mythique est en train de
remplacer le monstrueux jeunes de
banlieue dans les imaginaires français
c'est le réfugié
je vous remercie de l'attention